let's say that we run abc watch factory
and we want to understand the economics
of our business so what we have in this
table is some data that we've already
been able to estimate or measure
based on how our business is running and
then we're going to be able to figure
out some other things based on this data
so this first column is fixed cost or
monthly fixed costs so these are the
things that we can't really change in
the short run regardless of how many
people we hire or how many units we
produce so that might be the rent on our
facilities or the cost of renting the
equipment and so for us that's five
thousand dollars a month
then you have your labor units and for
the sake of this this model we'll say
that a labor unit is a full-time
employee who's at the factory working
every working day in a month and so you
can see we can go from one person
working every
full working full time every working day
in a month all the way up to six
now this is the variable cost and for
simplicity this is mainly driven by the
labor units in a real world example it
would be driven by the labor units it
would be driven by
how much material we're using to produce
the watches but we have our variable
cost right over here and then we have
our total cost which is just simply the
fixed cost
plus the variable cost for any given
level of labor units and then we know
how many watches we can produce in a
month based on our number of labor units
or you could view it as based on our
total cost or based on our fixed and
variable costs
now what we have here are other things
that we would want to look at if we
really want to un understand how our
factory works so this is the marginal
product of labor mpl for short then you
have your marginal cost then you have
your average variable cost then you have
your average fixed cost and then you
have your average total cost so like
always pause this video and try to fill
out what these values would be for even
one row of this table and then i'll do
it with you
all right now let's do it together let's
start with marginal product of labor
let's remind ourselves what that is that
says for every incremental labor unit
how much are we how much more are we
able to produce and so we'd have to
start at the second one because we have
to think about an incremental labor unit
so as we go from one to two labor units
we were able to go from 10 to 25
total output so we were able to produce
15 more watches i could just type in 15
but it's even better to do it with a
formula so i can just scroll it down the
rest of the rows so in this formula i
want to find the difference in my total
output
so 25 that cell
minus this cell
so that's saying hey look i was able to
grow
15 output or increase my output by 15
when i increased labor by
minus
1.
and then i got my marginal product of
labor is 15 when i went from 1 employee
to 2
and then i can just figure that out for
the other rows that's the value of using
a spreadsheet my marginal product of
labor when i went from two employees to
three employees is 20. so that means by
adding that third employee i'm able to
produce 20 more watches per month and so
you might be noticing two interesting
trends here initially my marginal
product of labor seems to be increasing
and then it seems to be decreasing and
that's consistent with way a lot of
businesses or factories work
which is initially you're getting the
benefits of specialization where
if you only have one person working in
your factory they have to do everything
they have to polish the glass and bring
in the boxes and talk to your suppliers
and and fit the gears on your watches
and whatever and do the wiring while as
you add more people they can start to
specialize one person can specialize on
assembly another person can specialize
on bringing the boxes in and so
initially you have these benefits of
specialization and so people can focus
in on just one skill and do it well but
then you start getting diminishing
returns the office starts getting
crowded people are waiting for different
supplies they have to get out of each
other's way and so then you see this
diminishing return trend where the
marginal product of labor starts going
down for those incremental labor units
next we'll think about marginal cost and
as we'll see the marginal cost trends go
in the other direction as the marginal
product of labor so marginal cost is
just for every for a certain increment
increment in output how much is that
costing us so for example if we are
going from
10 to 50 to 25 output for that 15
increment in output how much is that
costing us and i would say costing us on
average but i don't want to get confused
we're not talking about average variable
cost or average fixed cost or average
total cost but that would be let's see
our costs
went from
7 000 to 11 000. so we'll do 11 000
minus 7 000 that is our change in cost
divided by our change in total output so
that's going to be divided by the 25
minus the 10.
and we could just scroll this down
or extend that formula and you can see
this trend that as the marginal product
of labor is increasing your marginal
cost is decreasing that makes sense or
in some ways we're getting more
efficient through the specialization
what else but then once you have
diminishing returns diminishing marginal
returns your marginal cost is going up
and now we can do the i guess you could
say the average cost so first average
variable cost well that's just taking
your variable cost and dividing it by
your total output
and so
for at least those first 25 units they
cost on average or just the variable
component you have to be careful is 240
dollars if we talk about the fixed
component well that's just going to be
our fixed cost
divided by
our total units
and then our average total cost well
that's going to be our total cost
divided by those 25 units and so you can
see our average total cost for those
first 25 units is 440
and then it can be broken up between how
much of that 440 is variable versus
fixed and then we can just extend these
formulas down
the magic of spreadsheets
and what's interesting here and it's not
going to be going to be so obvious just
looking at this spreadsheet is something
interesting is happening when marginal
cost seems to intersect either your
average variable cost or your average
total cost that at some point your
average variable cost you see that same
trend it's trending down and then it
starts to trend up again average total
cost is trending down but then it trends
up again and as we'll see when we graph
it the point at which marginal cost
intersects with the average variable
cost that's when you have that change in
direction of average variable cost and
the same thing is true when marginal
cost intersects with average total cost
that's when you have that change in
direction
average fixed cost just continues to go
down because those fixed costs aren't
going up as you have more and more
output so you have those same fixed
costs you could view it as spread spread
amongst more and more output so that's
just going to keep asymptoting downward
and the next video will actually graph
that and see these trends visually